[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview
a first look at what is on the front
pages as they arrive coming up
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the pr consultant alex dean
and the director of the demos think tank
polly mckenzie they'll be
with us right through until midnight so
let's see what is on
some of those front pages well french
holiday chaos
is the splash for the mail as a last
minute exception
has been made meaning that even people
who've had both doses
of the covid vaccine must still
quarantine for 10 days
upon returning from france well the
times has virtually
the same headline and says hundreds of
thousands of people are likely to be
affected
by that change well that development is
also
the lead story for the telegraph the
mirror
meanwhile quotes the government's chief
medical officer professor chris witte
warning that it may be necessary to
reimpose lockdown within five weeks if
the number of cases
of the virus keeps on rising and the
guardian has spoken to a downing street
source who calls the increase
in infections worrying and the financial
times
carries criticism from health experts
around the world
who believe boris johnson is doing the
wrong thing by lifting restrictions on
monday
the sun is concerned it may not be
possible to hold barbecues in the coming
days that's after thousands of staff
at a meat factory were pinged by the nhs
app
meanwhile the express forecasts
temperatures of
90 degrees fahrenheit this weekend
and the star reacts to that news by
invoking the memory of the late caroline
ahern
in their headline scorchio well we're
joined
tonight by alex dean and paulie mckenzie
good evening to both of you good to see
you both i didn't
uh envy the job of various newspaper sub
editors this evening did you of that
last
minute announcement coming about these
changes
to travelers coming back from france we
start
uh polly with the front page of the
daily mail simply says
french holiday chaos
well i think they're bang on because
this happened
has come even though hundreds of
thousands of people will have
already booked holidays in france some
may already be in france
all on the assumption that for those of
us who
have been duplicated after quarantine
when we got home again
and that is now uh not gonna happen so
even if you're double vaccinated even if
you do repeated tests
you will have to quarantine if you are
coming back from france
um and there's also there's rumors
circulating that they might even
consider
putting france on the red line which
would require people to
have a hotel quarantine now that's still
very much a kind of
it's not being denied that it's being
considered sort of uh
level of possibility and this is
happening because of
the south african variant which is very
prevalent uh i think now called the beta
variant
now very prevalent in france which has a
particular
low vaccine efficacy for the astrazeneca
vaccine they stopped using astrazeneca
in south africa partly because of
that reason and lots of people in the uk
have the astrazeneca vaccine so
public health officials are very worried
about trying to keep that beta variant
out we have are dominated by the delta
variant
at the moment and i can't think what's
next yeah and it's also a very similar
front page on the front page of the
times
there a lot of speculation though ahead
of this announcement that
was this to do with public health
because if you look at the figures
the number of cases in france relatively
very low
compared to other some other european
countries certainly compared
to the uk is is there some politics at
play here
yes uh polly gamma would be next um i
think what um
we are looking at now is a situation in
which our rate
on the face of it is much worse than uh
the rate in france and we you know on
that logic you might think we would
encourage people to be
in that environment rather than um
discouraging them from going there
or punishing them for coming back what
we've effectively done
is to create a position between the
list and the red list there's now a new
uh position
and the plus i suppose or red minus that
we've now put
france into at no notice awful for
anyone
seeking to go of course the government's
trying to do the right thing
but having this sort of thing thrust
upon you right at the very last moment
is the kind of thing that is going to
make thousands of people's lives a
misery
in the coming weeks and over these
summer holidays but i do think more
generally sam
there's another point to be taken from
this because and polly was kind of it
was getting at it
that we're increasingly treating the
vaccinated
as if they were unvaccinated and we're
going to rub out a lot of kind of public
goodwill in the sense that we're in this
together
and that we're going to get through it
and come out the other side because the
message for so long has been
that that jabs were the way out the
vaccine was the way that we were going
to get back to normality
and instead now we are reversing and
we're going back to situations where
people who have been vaccinated
are being treated and like in this case
as if they haven't been vaccinated at
all
it's really worrying more generally it's
not just about france the direction of
travel here is bad
yeah there's a lot of i suppose with
uncertainty
polly i mean that that's not at all what
the travel industry wanted is it
mixed messaging no it's it's
catastrophic for the travel industry i
mean we saw
earlier in the week the the shift of the
balearic islands obviously a massive
holiday
destination for brits you know was met
with
uh horror and you know real upset by by
the travel industry
this is always gonna be a really
difficult balance and that
you know travel and hospitality are the
devastated by by these and you know it
may be that
more intervention is is needed by both
you know within this and more broadly by
other countries
to support those kind of ascent
sectors for all of humanity so that
they aren't just dominated by airline
and hotel
bankruptcies because of this incredible
uncertainty
yeah i suppose we should uh point out
that you can as it stands
uh still test and release can't you
after five days if you decide
to still go to france but you can
understand why a lot of people might
be concerned um about still going
let's talk about the front page of the
sun alex
oberger is the headline and just to add
final indignity to all of the um
uncertainty around the summer a ping
threat
to barbecue meat supplies well it's a
genuine
issue and it's in a number of the
insides of the newspapers too
that um workforces are being threatened
to
are being there's a threat that they
won't get back up to meaningful scale
or come back away from meaningful scale
having got there because people are
being required to self-isolate in such
numbers now
and the government has said it won't
reduce the um sensitivity of the ping
register
despite the fact that people are getting
pinged through their walls when their
neighbors have come back reporting have
been
in contact with people and so forth and
what it's meaning
is that lots of factories are losing
entire production lines because they
haven't got the workers to man them
and the sun's got hold of this as always
in a way that's quite kind of
eye-catching and evocative and points
out that
one of our biggest meat processing
plants is
unlikely to be able to continue in
operation because of this but more
generally
it looks like we're going to have port
operations frustrated
um infrastructure rail frustrated
because we are
going to be requiring people up into the
millions quite likely
uh to self-isolate if we carry on in
these numbers uh the institute of
economic affairs is quoted in one of
these newspapers saying
it'll set back our economic recovery by
months
if we carry on in this direction yeah
it's the irony isn't it polly just very
briefly to you
that just as we're trying to get the
economy back on track with the final
removal of all these restrictions and
half the people can't go to work
yeah and it's a reminder that it's not
as simple as you just end the
restrictions and then people can go back
to normal
because the ending the restrictions
actually enables cases to rise which
leads to more pings
if we had the restrictions in place
there'd probably be
fewer pings because cases wouldn't have
risen or be right you know
expected to rise potentially to a
hundred thousand a day according to
some um to some projections and it's
that question between our
our kind of normal everyday freedoms and
uh
essential service workers like people in
burn factories but also
you know a range of other essential
services um
them being able to work and so in a way
we get off
the kind of general population freedom
is causing a
wider consequence for the kind of
essential infrastructure
yeah who knew that pinged was going to
be such a regular part of our vocabulary
these days
uh polly alex stay tight we'll be back
with you after
the break coming up could the decision
to press ahead with reopening mean that
we
could soon be back in a lockdown we'll
be discussing that
jolly prospect coming up next
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me uh back again alex dean
and polly mckenzie let's take a look if
we can
uh polly at the front page of the daily
mirror and never mind
people's holidays to france being
cancelled and this one says
lock down in five weeks fear and it's
quoting um
professor chris witte describing the
rise and number of cases here
as quite scary
yeah i mean you'll remember that you
know early in the year
the whole rollout this unlocking down
plan
was designed to be irreversible and they
that was how they bought permission to
go
slowly was this promise that we would go
slowly enough that it would be the end
of it once it was over
and cases are now so high chris whitie
is quoted sort of saying we've
we've doubled and we've doubled again
we've doubled the deaths we've doubled
the hospitalizations and we've doubled
the cases
don't have to go through many doublings
before that gets
out of control and really very scary and
so they are warning though
public health officials have have done
this throughout that we might need to
kind of
junk that concept of it being
irreversible and once the summer comes
to the
towards its end we might need to lock
down again
yeah well that's uh really the front
page of the guardian isn't it alex
talking about
um you know as we approach the 19th and
what some people
and some of the newspapers have been
describing as
freedom day you know should should we be
doing that given
the state of affairs with the number of
infections
yes an increasing effort isn't there
from the public health lobby to
suggest that the government is isolated
internationally
and that this is an experiment or it's
reckless we have waited for a great deal
of time
to be released but witty's counsel as uh
polly rightly describes it is clear
that um doubling and doubling again
leads in a very dangerous direction
i also think this if you read the runes
here in some of these newspapers
you can see some interesting messaging
from the government on that point polly
was mentioning
about the cautious but irreversible
nature of the unlocking
because it's lucy fraser the solicitor
general who is speculating that we might
have to have new restrictions not a
health care professional
not a journalist asking mischievous
questions it's a serving member of the
government in senior post who's
suggesting
we may have to go back into some kind of
lockdown at that point you think the
government's seeking
to lay the groundwork for a possible
reversal yeah the language has certainly
changed doesn't it and
and the ft uh taking a a more holistic
view here talking about
the actions taken in the uk by boris
johnson
not just putting people at risk here but
it
it's putting people at risk all over the
world polly
yeah because what you have to remember
is that
the dreadful disease is mutating all the
time
and so the more people have it the more
possibility there is
for mutations alex and i were discussing
the greek alphabet earlier
i think we've actually already had the
gamma uh
bonzita and eta but there's a lambda
variant
uh and the next one i think would be mu
what we don't want is for one of those
new variants to emerge that can
really really break through the vaccines
we know there's an impact
of some of these variants on vaccine
efficacy but we haven't had something
that just
powers through it and that's the and
it's a risk that if
you know if we had the kent variant
which emerged
in the uk last autumn if another very
emerged from this pool of infections
with
emitting that could then spread around
the world and cause
uh you know another nation